you started
market snacks as an independent
podcast we started as a media company
back in 2011 in secret when we were
working at banks november 2011 but we
started our friendship four and a half
years prior that's true
total serendipity freshman year remains
walked into the room jack had the same
protein shake as me and the same
daily show dvds no i had season three of
seinfeld you had season four that's true
and we were watching the daily show on
hulu which had just launched that was
like a cool new thing little do we know
there was gonna be a roku a hulu a tibu
where would you guys go columbia
middlebury college met at middlebury
college where's that vermont beautiful
city
jason i thought we would have colleges
in vermont all right just take it easy
all the fans from vermont or emailing
stop composing i'm just trolling so you
start this market snacks it becomes a
podcast the newsletter what is it
trolling on twitter it was a blog we had
a wordpress 10.99 a month uh we started
a blog in november of 2011. and actually
on that day we wrote our first blog post
we have not missed a day of market
action when the new york stock exchange
is open since and that began with us
literally we'd get out of our bank jobs
we recognized one day that business news
just was not communicating with our
generation right we committed to doing
it every day since then and we literally
would like get out of bank jobs be on
the subway texting with stories to cover
curating the stories relevant to our
generation and getting it out later that
night the daily blog became a daily
email newsletter which expanded to video
like tv appearances giving the
millennial perspective on finance got it
which expanded to a podcast when you say
the millennial perspective on finance
you mean is this the month where i get
off mom and dad's netflix and go on my
own and take out my credit cards we did
a whole segment trick question you never
get off the netflix password okay
password mooching is still strong yeah
now do you have driver's licenses yes
when did you get them
16 actually in vermont you get a
learner's permit when you're 15. in new
york i was one of the very few who got a
driver's license yes okay nick's when
nick drove up to middlebury college to
meet me as his freshman year roommate
this was it's the first time he had ever
made a gradual turn with the wheel i
don't want it in manhattan it's 90
degree angles yeah yeah you have this
square is the entire time it's a grid
it's a grid system it's easy to
understand it's thoughtful this i mean
broadway does go against the grid
but in a very specific way yes it hits
each of those columbus circle herald
square it does it very organized fashion
the only road that goes tip to tip on
management now as millennials you go to
college you guys meet each other and
then whose mom's basement do you move
back into right
it's do we find another mom there
actually should be like how does that
platform for that we both got gigs
actually and finally both got a job
right after yes where'd you go morgan
stanley i went to coleman's bank or
commerce bank which is a german bank for
the new york branch and i was at ubs so
jack was down in the financial district
and i was up in midtown ubs this is the
bank that uh
backed
different story different story they
might be very into russian money
and turning it from rubles into
us dollars
what's a great way to do that
real estate yeah it's a great city to
buy real estate in
new york new york yeah and florida yeah
wait hmm interesting i think deutsche
bank actually owns a couple casinos they
do it they went to casinos not just
trump's casinos but other casinos which
went bankrupt and they repossessed
casinos and are running casinos
really interesting okay now at some
point
robin hood oh my robin hood yeah um
full disclosure i'm an investor in robin
hood from the early days it's done okay
from what i understand i don't get very
many updates from vlad
uh but uh from what i understand
everything the trades are doing okay how
does vlad update investors actually he
doesn't you know
he does if you had a
preferred way we can deliver a message
yeah just a an email every year okay
just how many paid members we have or
somebody i don't really ask them you
know when you're an investor an angel
investor
you when you don't get updates it means
one of two things
the company is going gonna go public and
you're gonna make a ton of money or the
company's about to go out of business
and they're gonna be asking you for a
bridge any minute yeah it's one of those
two yeah so
you just take the good with the bad if
you don't hear from them you just hope
it's the one out of 20 times that uber
didn't hear from travis for six months
until he was like yeah by the way we
just closed that 20 billion close what
he's like money revenue the infrequent
email seems to be the optimal the
funniest moment with uber was
they had asked them
what the share price was they told me
the share price and then i when i
calculated what i had and i said wow
that's incredible and they said oh
you you that's where'd you get that
share count from and i said well i'm
just looking at the documents i said oh
you you don't know about the seven to
one and i said what's the seven to one
and they said we did seven to one stock
split i said what does that mean it says
well you have seven times the number of
shares wow whoa and i was like
hold on one second let's put them on
hold on angel life
jesus um all right
so at some point you guys are chugging
along did you get to like multiple
people is just a two-man show and then
vlad wants to buy it this is like
literally well this is a few years down
the line we've been we're growing as a
side hustle like there are points where
jack is on business in germany i'm on
business in in brazil and we're like
still we're making market snacks happen
there are times where jack and i are
like before we go to work we're putting
you know going down to new york stock
exchange having makeup put on our face
appearing on cheddar tv doing a hit at
cbs then going to our day jobs and then
running the newsletter in the evening we
both disclosed outside business
interests to our banks very true
eventually yes right before we monetized
and that's when we started going with
like an how quickly did they pull you
into hr and what is that conversation
like uh i came up voluntarily yeah um we
actually didn't have our names on market
snacks.com for the first like year and a
half yeah uh because we were nervous we
just didn't want them to shut it down
yeah but then we had our first
advertiser our first revenue stream this
was back in like early 2013 i think and
then we're like this is clearly a
business oh and we opened an llc at that
point yeah and that's when i went to
henning von garzdorf great guy my german
boss
and i was like sure he's got a great
sense of humor
so i convinced him that market snacks
you know we're covering financial news
every day i will be able to talk to my
clients about the financial markets i'll
be a better writer i'll be a better
worker there we go that's why you should
approve this and he did and did he
didn't say to you like well you built
this while we were here and so we own it
yes
what percentage do we own no nicknames
we're seeing mine snacks these are
personal email addresses yes and texting
snacks newsletters you know this was
actually a did you update the blog from
our laptop
we this thing we learned early on which
is i think really different from a
couple decades ago which is
companies are really much more open to
the idea of you having a side hustle
yeah and if you're up front and
communicate this properly this is a
great incubator
the opposite of what you can
ask for forgiveness not permission yeah
that's another option anyway you went to
your boss as well i actually had by
chance just changed company to work for
a venture firm in new york oh really
it's fun it's called endeavor it's
actually a non-profit structured like a
venture firm they have an arm out here
called catalyst which is very cool
chobani is a
an endeavor company no it's not but
that'd be really you mean the greek
yogurt
it's focused on emerging markets and
basically reaching scale-up
entrepreneurs and emerging markets you
guys start making a little chatter
yes and then what robin hood's like we
want to create something you guys got
as an advertiser how did you meet so we
were we were uh the two-person company
we're the hosts of the newsletter um we
we generated our own revenues through
our own ad sales eventually we went full
in on market snacks and we gave it our
100 percent focus in the summer of 2000
did you quit your job
uh actually we had gone to business
school both of us were basically
university of michigan and i was at
warden and we saw business school is
actually an accelerator like a way for
us to take classes put the info right
back into the product which we actually
were doing like with the marketing
classes in particular so instead of
taking a typical mba internship nick and
i
i like stopped financing from the
entrepreneur center at michigan they
gave me some money to like do my own
thing and we put everything into market
snacks and we launched our podcast in
may of 2018 and that took market snacks
to a new level right that was our second
core product
and that was our major differentiator we
got is there like a move where like you
blink with your left eye to let him know
you're done talking
the amount of time between when you stop
talking and he starts is the same as the
time between your words individually
it's a wavelength interpretation thing
we established freshman year look he
visited me and brought he just did it
when i was studying abroad here we go we
played
you know a whole bunch of drinking games
in college can i get in on this so wait
you do it to him and then you do it to
me
and so you you got to do it to him so
tell me about when you met vlad
so we met vlad
after we so actually let me just back
you up for one second
robin hood approached us and said hey
you guys have a cool newsletter we would
love to reach your audience with an ad
perfect so they were the newsletter
sponsor for one week
but they were asking questions that
seemed a little beyond the realm of the
business transfer right it was like much
more like we had we had taken a round of
investment from a company called rough
draft ventures earlier that summer and
the meeting we had with robin hood's
marketing department was much more like
that fundraising round there then they
said
hayley at some point
what do you guys think about the future
of market snacks have you thought about
your future we said we're thinking big
we want to be the top financial source
for people under 30 and then we shared
more that we basically would have put in
a pitch deck to an investor and did you
get stock or cash when you made the
acquisition both we can't talk about all
the details of the acquisition but it
really was
a unique moment because that entire
summer and the few months afterwards
negotiating it were just an incredible
experience so do you regret taking some
cash instead of all stock
we have no regrets about never regrets
now i don't think so yeah